I was already claiming this [ __ ] but  then that's when you know [ __ ] started  happening over there shootings uh it was  wild bro it was like you couldn't even  walk down the street without worrying  about like somebody pulling up or  somebody trying to play with you and say  what's up and get you to the car and  shoot you it was wild bro get you to the  car and shoot oh it's the most devious  [ __ ] I ever heard yeah it was fun over  there I mean I I learned I learned a lot  of [ __ ] I got adopted at seven days old  oh okay black family well to a black  mother  um you got adopted wait was it a friend  of the family she just went to the  orphanage I want this white baby I met  my grandmother with the biological  grandmother she was uttered in long  sleeve shirts at the time so I'm pretty  sure she did  machete  [Music]